[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker our good buddy the former
nfl offensive lineman host of the ross
tucker football podcast and uh you can
uh check out the ross tucker football
podcast also a game analyst for the
eagles in their pre-season also does
some college football and nfl for cbs in
westwood one
ross joins us now how would you answer
that the most iconic nfl team in history
is
uh you know for me it's probably either
the packers or the steelers and it was
interesting dan hearing you guys talk
about it you know what it really is like
for all of us our age group
it's whoever was featured the most on
nfl films from the 60s and 70s
you know like that is what's iconic i
can just picture vince lombardi you know
and all those videos come on guys let's
go the green bay power sweep or the
videos of like lin swan being in the air
for 48 seconds catching passes in super
bowls i think it's hard for any other
team
to be more iconic than the teams that
were so
revered and featured on those nfl films
videos from the 60s and 70s yeah it's
like they had a head start because they
were successful at a time when we didn't
get to watch all of the games maybe you
got to see your team featured with
howard cosell on monday night football
with the three-minute highlights but
i would probably i don't think there's a
wrong answer if it's the cowboy steelers
packers or raiders it just depends on
you know what was
your fandom growing up and was it based
off your dad or your grandfather because
that's usually where it starts if you're
a fan of that team now and you're in
your 30s chances are it was based off of
who your dad was rooting for how
important is pre-season
well i think to the teams themselves i
think we saw last year
probably not all that important uh to
the players that are playing tonight
it's everything i mean i had some guy on
twitter
hit me up at ross tucker nfl and say
preseason doesn't mean
you know what
and i just replied back to him dan you
know there's 90 man rosters right we
won't see hardly any starters tonight
so there's at least 50 guys playing
tonight okay
that were two-time all-state
two-time all-conference in college
maybe the best athlete to ever come from
their hometown
that the two and a half three quarters
they play tonight it's the most
important game of their lives i'm
talking about guys 50 to 90 on the
roster certainly
65 to 90 on each roster it's the most
important game of their life so if you
don't care about that that's fine that
doesn't bother me i get it you just want
the starters you just want the games
that count that's fine but number one to
those guys it means everything and
number two
just don't tell me you're that you're
the biggest fan ever like i always laugh
when people are like i'm a die hard
cowboy i'm the biggest fan ever but they
don't watch the preseason like there are
a lot of fans out there they watch every
second of the preseason because they
care about the third string tight end
and the o-line depth and they want to
know who the fourth corner will be and
it's totally acceptable if you don't
feel that way just do me a favor don't
call yourself the biggest fan ever
how do you make a roster during
preseason if you're a borderline player
uh two things number one is
you first of all it starts by doing
something to stand out
you know there's 90 guys now there's
only 80 guys dan when i was playing but
with 90 guys especially if you're one of
these
bottom of the roster undrafted guys you
must do something unique or different to
stand out
and
mine was
taking the aggression to another level
right like having the coaches have to
tell me to calm down that's one way they
love that you know like joe judge has
all the giants players running and doing
push-ups meanwhile the next day he's
like i gotta be honest that really
turned me on i really liked that they
they all act like they don't like fights
dan they're all full of it okay
if you're a football coach it's because
at one point you loved football and you
played it which means you loved the
physical part of it which means you love
that you love it i mean dan campbell at
least admits it i love dan campbell dan
campbell's like oh that was amazing just
that like at least he says it so number
one
you have to stand out in some way and
number two
the coaches have to trust you
they have to trust you
which means you cannot mess up mentally
honestly dan i wasn't that physically
gifted but i never messed up mentally i
always did what the coaches wanted me to
do i blocked the right guy the way they
wanted me to block him and then i tried
to kill the guy to the best of my
ability and that's like the only reason
i made it with schottenheimer as a
rookie and then stuck around for a while
but
i guess you get cut then if you do mess
up something mentally
if your alignment i'm guessing
yeah any position dan uh it is the
single biggest reason
why guys don't make it
i think nfl football is way more
complicated or at least detailed then
people realize i can't tell i mean i've
seen guys that bench pressed 600 pounds
they just couldn't figure it out i've
seen guys that were way more talented
than me
they didn't know who to block when the
defense would change their alignment and
honestly some of the guys dan i actually
felt bad for there was a kid i remember
he was really gifted he spent every
second dan studying the playbook and if
you would ask him he would know it you'd
say well what happens if they do this
right they do that
but then when he actually got out there
dan
and they're flying around and it happens
in a split second it's a different type
of intelligence
and some guys
it comes very naturally for and other
guys
really struggle with it and if you
really struggle
with the football iq the fbi
if you will football intelligence you're
gonna have a really tough time sticking
around the nfl as a player
more intriguing team this season the
steelers of the cowboys
they're both pretty intriguing i'm gonna
say steelers
because of what happened last year
because of a totally new offensive line
and because of big ben i mean i go on in
pittsburgh radio
i live in central pennsylvania there
were a lot
of people in pittsburgh including you
know radio guys and fans
they wanted the team to move on for big
ben
and they wanted to turn the page they
thought big ben and think that big ben's
washed up they wanted to see what mason
rudolph could do
in his last year under contract and or
turn the page and get the next i thought
they were nuts i think the steelers did
the right thing giving ben one last
chance especially
when you have a roster with cam hayward
and minka fitzpatrick and tj watt and
these guys
i think that those guys and ben have
earned the right to make one more run at
this thing i mean they were 11-0 last
year i thought they were the best team
in the nfl until the wheels came off
how many legitimate super bowl
contenders do you think we have this
year
maybe six
so chiefs buccaneers
so in the nfc
maybe three
green bay
and
maybe the rams i don't see the niners or
the seahawks getting there so in the nfc
i'm saying maybe three and i think even
the rams are dubious
in the afc
it's obviously kansas city
i would say buffalo
cleveland
nobody in the afc south nobody else afc
west i don't think
is legit
i'm saying six total i'm saying the six
i just gave you three in each in each
conference
uh and i wonder if our expectations a
little high on the rams because
as soon as they got matthew stafford i
said i don't know what the odds are but
that's my mvp pick and then all of a
sudden
i started to see where there were a lot
of people who thought oh the rams they
could go to the super bowl and matthew
stafford could be the mvp like peter
king was gushing that matthew stafford
is going to throw for 6 000 yards
i i i don't know our
expectation level a little too high for
the rams
i think it is um look i think matthew
stafford is better than jared goff
but i don't think it's as pronounced
everybody else seems to think
i mean most of these years if you looked
at quarterback rankings
stafford was probably somewhere between
10 and 15
and golf might have been between 15 and
20.
i don't know i mean how much of a
difference is that dan is that is it a
two or three win difference is that
super bowl or not i don't know i mean
and by the way when they get stafford
they lose john johnson and troy hill
both those guys went to cleveland so
they lost two of the guys that were
really good in their secondary i mean
you know they gained stafford but they
lost some other guys
and i'm just fascinated by them i mean
they they have no first round picks
forever
they have no middle class they have
elite guys
and guys making the minimum and it's
kind of working for him we'll see if it
works this year what mclove and you're
rolling your eyes back there at ross
tucker well stafford was ranked 10 to 15
when he was with the lions now that he's
with sean mcvay and the rams don't you
think he'll possibly move up that
ranking
i mean he might that's certainly what
they're counting on i guess what i would
say about the sean mcvay thing always
makes me laugh
he's obviously a good coach right
but you ever noticed how for four years
every time the rams scored a bunch of
points it was sean mcvay oh my gosh sean
mc i sound like paulie doing my
impersonation right there sean mcvay oh
my gosh he's the greatest coach of all
time he's got the best hair
he's got a great house by the way
when when whenever the rams stunk it was
or they didn't do anything on offense
jared goff stinks it's all jared goff's
fault you can't have it both ways dan
you can't you can't everything positive
can't be mcvay and everything negative
is golf like let's let's split up both
of them a little bit yeah but that
happens with kyle shanahan when that
offense is clicking that's kyle
shanahan's offense but when it's not
that jimmy garoppolo can't play
it's a great point it's a great point
they both deserve uh a slice of the
success and
futility pie i agree
uh it's great to talk to you and uh
what do you mention right now
not enough uh oh by the way how about
this
last friday on the beach okay
i i i did an hour walk on the beach and
every five minutes i did 20 push-ups so
i had done 160 push-ups
and then at the end i wanted to like rep
out i'm 256 pounds i did 42 push-ups i
did my age in push-ups
after doing 160 so i don't like i don't
i don't max out but that's my new thing
until i die
i want to be able to do my age and
push-ups going to get tough in my 70s
certainly my 80s but i want to try to do
my age and push-ups
who's the strongest guy you were ever
around either teammate played against um
well
i was teammates with larry allen
who was ridiculously strong i think he
benched like 700 pounds but there was a
guy
there was a guy chris valerio who i play
with in buffalo he's actually the head
coach at uh saint francis which is an
fcs school polly probably watches all
their games live um out in western pa i
saw him they drafted a kid dan this is a
true story we we drafted a kid out of
vanderbilt
that benched 600 pounds
and so there was a discussion on the
bills
who's the strongest guy
so we go to valerio who like in his
eighth year and we're like
you know what you gotta do right like i
mean he's like 32 years old we're like
you know he's like yeah i know i know
he puts
495
[Music]
on the incline incline bench
and reps it out for 10
gets off the bench and like stares at
the vanderbilt rookie just like and we
were like yeah
yeah
it was awesome it was meathead
meatheadness at its finest
uh
and you're the uh the president and a
and a member
proud member yes of course i'm surprised
we're not doing this on a meet friday
every friday i see that tweet and i get
so jealous uh it's great to talk to you
we'll check in with you during the
season ross thank you all right see you
guys that's ross tucker former nfl
offensive lineman and host of the ross
tucker football podcast
nice